one way to have guaranteed employment in
the nfl is to be great another way is to
be pretty damn good but also have the
circumstances line up in a way that
favors your ongoing employment that
brings us to the minnesota vikings and
general manager rick spielman who by the
way will be a guest later today on pft
p.m spielman yesterday addressing the
rumors that have been ricocheting around
the nfl that maybe the vikings would be
willing to trade quarterback kirk
cousins here's
spielman yeah i think coach zim put that
to bed when he spoke after the season
kirk cousins is our quarterback i know
there's a lot of
rumors floating around out there but
kirk cousins is our quarterback we felt
that he played very well and probably
the best uh he's ever played down that
stretch last year and the way he played
so um that we yeah kirk kirk's got
quarterback going forward and uh
look forward to him another year in his
system
and uh and and excited for him and what
he's going to bring to our team next
year
that that little tell they're looking
for another year in this system it's
like oh crap you know gary kubiak's gone
and we hope klein is the answer you okay
the system won't be won't beat it was he
does the quick little it's a little tell
there oh okay
don't play poker with mike rick don't
play poker with mike he's got you he's
got you down you it's like the uh
rounders when he twists the uh oreo
right and he hears it in his ear or he
does that right in his ear and then he
knows oh kgb yeah teddy kgb um you okay
though you all right you gonna make it
what is this what is today love me not
or love me yesterday or what how do we
feel about it today
every day is an accept reality day
because you're in a damn thing i can do
about it look
here's the reality for the vikings i've
said this before
they need kirk cousins this year yeah
because this is the year that if they
they don't fulfill what has become
kind of a depressing trend
no playoffs in the even number of years
playoffs in the odd-numbered years this
is a playoff year you know for as well
as he played last year they didn't get
to the playoffs yeah so
this year i think
is the worst year for them to
potentially try out a different
quarterback because if they don't get to
the playoffs after this year there could
be some changes made in minnesota
cousins helps them avoid the changes and
checks the box on odd number gear
playoffs so if you get to the playoffs
in the odd-numbered year you can get
away with no playoffs in the even
numbered year and then you're back at it
2023 pressure's back on to get to the
playoffs again and yeah my my take on
the vikings has become and i'm
i've been candid about this i've written
about it spoken about it
i feel like organizationally
they are willing to be just good enough
to just be in contention you know that's
how you make your money as a
professional football team you don't
have to be a super bowl champion you
just have to be good enough that you're
interesting that you're relevant that
you're
that you're in the mix for a post-season
birth every year up until week 16 or 17
and one year you get in and one year you
don't and when we get to the super bowl
uh it doesn't matter that's that's icing
on top of the icing on top of the cherry
on top of the icing on top of the cake
at that point what matters is making
money and the way you make money is you
be relevant every year not burn out and
go all in one year and then the next
year or the year after you're like how
the hell are we ever going to get back
to the playoffs they're content to just
have kind of that that you know one year
in one year out and just kind of ha and
that i feel like that's where they are
as an organization they're content
am i wrong
am i wrong yes you're wrong you're wrong
bring that theory up to rick today on
pft pm okay
i will i don't think he's sitting there
going hey i just want to stay in the
middle me and zimmer want to stay in the
middle that's what we're doing not the
middle not the middle okay the the just
uh just enough above
so the stadium is full
the fan base is engaged and every year
the carrot dangles
right for all those vikings fans that
have said we would just like to win one
championship in our lifetimes they're
dangling the carrot there so every year
they can they can delude themselves at
some point in the offseason into
thinking that this year is the year i
feel like that that's that's the scam at
this point
again
when these teams tell us we want to win
the super bowl this year they are lying
to you yeah they'd like to it would be
nice what they want to do is fill the
stadium and make as much money as
possible it's business
and they don't want us to say it's
business it's okay to love football and
still regard it for what it is hey
plenty of people love wrestling even
though they know it's fake
football is business we can love
football and say it's still a business
and that allows us to understand why
teams do what they do but if your
measure of success is winning the super
bowl 31 teams are gonna be pissed off
sorry london every year okay that's just
how it works well yeah of course yes
that is how it works but i don't think
they're sitting back playing to be just
above the middle of the pack i don't you
know they've done a lot of great things
they really have they were in the nfc
championship game not too long ago yeah
they had a quarterback well they had a
quarterback too that had a freak injury
and that threw things off they pushed
the chips into the middle of the table a
few times they've drafted really well
okay it hasn't worked out to
mike florio's liking but i'm not going
to accept that you're just saying that
spielman and them want to be right above
the middle of the pack i'm not and kirk
cousins listen again like derek carr
it's it's okay yes he's not a superstar
but
for the way they play in that offense
again another guy that's top 10-ish in
the league and show me a better option
you know again okay show me a better
option they can have at quarterback
right now than kirk cousins damn he
makes a lot of big throws and big plays
he's an easy guy to jump on i know he
kind of looks like a nerd a little bit
and it's not like sexy flair and he's in
a division with aaron rodgers throwing
missiles between his legs and around his
head and it makes him look ordinary at
times but damn he makes a lot of plays
and
yeah right now
what i respect about the vikings is i
mean here they are they're kind of
rebuilding and last year they're seven
and nine and we're in the thick of
things they they wiped the slate clean a
little bit last year and still played
competitive so i'm not giving up on your
team obviously today is a love you not
day with the minnesota vikings uh but
but uh i have a lot of respect for what
they do up there and i don't buy your
just a little above average take there
sorry well that's what they've been
that's what they've been i mean look
regardless of what the motivation is
what the plan is what the objective is
that's where they are that's who they
they traded for yannick way last year
they tried to make it yeah and then they
trip and then they traded him away the
moment they hit a rough patch and it
would have been nice to have him down
the stretch if you're the vikings well i
mean okay but you know they realize i
think they realize they got yannick and
gawkway
they realized wait to your point
we're not gonna win the super bowl this
year and do this it's not we're not
there so they're going all right let's
just maybe take a step back so we can
take two or three steps forward here in
the next few years and really build
something and they got a team that was
kind of desperate in the ravens to get a
pass rusher and they went for it so i i
i i like the way they run their football
team you know not everybody's the new
england patriots and can go and just win
super bowls every year that's what's
special about that football team man the
rest of the league it's you know they're
struggling for the most part on a
year-to-year basis unless you're kansas
city right now because you got patrick
mahomes and maybe uh aaron rodgers in
green bay and every everybody else is is
fighting for their damn life so um yeah
i'm gonna push back on you with that one
mr purple people eater
i i came to the conclusion when we were
in santa clara a year and a couple of
months ago for the vikings 49ers
division around game
that
there's always going to be
a dominant team in the nfc that the nf
that the vikings
run into and get smoked by in the
postseason i just feel like they're
they're not
constituted to be a team that can match
whatever that dominant team is that pops
up in a given year and i mean i've i've
i've been
following it for 50 years i just you
know it's you know it's
45 years now since their last super bowl
birth and they've lost six or seven nfc
championships i was at one of them the
one at giant stadium that was a good day
that was that was the one where they
were that it was over by three minutes
in the game it was over well it was it
was over three minutes into the game
first of all randy moss has a temper
tantrum on the sidelines before the game
because he couldn't get people down onto
the sideline that he wanted there i mean
come on focus on the football game and
then there was the troy walters who led
a kickoff land right in front of him and
looked at it after that
the giants recovered it's 14 nothing and
and then that that weird urban legend
about the giants
having intercepted the vikings coaching
communications it was never proven but
that was floating around
i don't know that i don't know that
anything would have mattered that day i
don't know that anything would have
mattered now i don't think so regardless
yeah why are we talking about that i
don't know anyway cause you're a viking
i'm will maybe
maybe i'll make a trade
with or at least an offer for rick
spielman
just deliver one super bowl trophy
however you have to do it dredge the
bottom of hillsborough river whatever
you have to do
get a super bowl trophy and i'll leave
you alone for the rest of my life
bring this up this will be great stuff i
mean please ask them all these questions
do this later on today and we'll talk
about it next week please don't waste it
tomorrow when i'm not here i want to be
able to dive into this and really
dissect the conversation
i'll have to say it until later in the
conversation because if i do it early
enough it may be a fairly short
interview so i'll have to work up to it
yeah you will all right
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports